[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kendall
[Music]
[Applause]
damn boy
[Music]
march madness of podcasting so it's just
like the real march madness but instead
of college basketball teams it's going
to be with our favorite comedians
podcasts so those 24 shows that you just
saw
those are gonna get whittled down into a
sweet 16 based on youtube subscriber
amounts i think that's the most fair way
to do seating uh then after that every
saturday in march starting tomorrow
saturday march 12th there's going to be
a poll in the joke world community
section and it's going to be the
matchups and you guys are going to get
to vote on who moves on to the next
rounds every saturday and then this
following sunday there's going to be a
quick video recapping what the results
were who's moving on and what the new
matchups are so without further ado i'm
going to show you the bracket it went
based on seating there were four number
one seeds and those were the people with
the foremost youtube subscribers so that
went to joe rogan experience your mom's
house this past weekend and two bears
one cave those are our one seeds and
then we'll get into the bracket all
right first round match-ups in region
one we have the number one overall seed
the joe rogan experience going up
against the 16 seed trash tuesdays and
then we have uncle joey's joint going up
against kill tony region two is your
mom's house versus the honeydew in the
first round and then tiger belly against
whiskey ginger which is obviously a very
interesting matchup bobby versus andrew
in the first round then we go on to
region three we have theo in this past
weekend starting off against chrissy
chaos
and then flagrant two against the king
and the sting and then finally in region
four two bears one cave against hey babe
in the first round and bad friends
against the tim dillon show which
personally i think is the most
interesting matchup of the first round
um so yeah every saturday there's going
to be a poll uploaded in the community
section make sure you go check out that
section and you're voting on these uh go
tell your friends who listen to these
shows who might not know about this
channel to vote i don't care if they
subscribe just you know let's get this
as authentic as we can the most fan
interaction and if you're like why are
you doing this it's because i like
sports and i like comedy and i think
this is gonna be really fun and it's
something that we get to all do together
you know the whole comedy community it'd
be really cool if we all came together
and just did like a fun little podcast
march madness tournament every saturday
make sure at the community section then
every sunday following that will be the
video recap to see who moves on also um
if you're wondering i did not include
congratulations podcast because that is
the one like true solo podcast um so it
didn't really fit in with everything
else and basketball is a team sport so
congratulations is is not in if you're
wondering what that is but everything
else was considered then the top 16
seeds again moved on the cool thing
about this is that it's not going to be
a popularity contest you know the the 16
seed could beat the one seed in the
first round if enough trash tuesday fans
voted and no joe rogan fans voted or if
you aren't a fan of either of those
podcasts and you want to root for an
underdog story you know anything could
happen just like in real march madness
when the one seed virginia lost in the
first round i think that was 2018 in the
real tournament you know that could
happen and it could be fun and and we
can crown a champ um so yeah
march with joke world is gonna be a lot
of madness and we're still gonna be
uploading our normal videos so if you're
thinking that this is going to be it for
the month that's not true we'll still be
uploading the normal content on our
channel and go tell your friends make
sure you're voting every saturday video
every sunday if you want a printable
bracket and you want to fill that out
and try to make a perfect bracket dm me
on instagram i'll send you one that you
can download and uh happy march madness
[Music]
you